[Music]
it's been an eventful 15 months for our
next guest here on pro football talk
live at the league meetings in arizona
he is entering his second season as
general manager of the green bay packers
brian gooda koontz welcome back thanks
for having me
good am i allowed to call you that are
we good enough friends yeah goody goody
is that what they call unity i like
goody okay it is i like it it's got it's
been a long time yep and i i butchered
your last name regularly through the
regular scene not regularly
all the
time yes that's all right uh sorry
i'm used to it by now that's for sure
okay
so uh
new head coach a lot of changes 56
million dollars in signing bonus money
that was allocated in free agency in the
early days if my math is correct and it
rarely is
why this year so aggressive right out of
the gates in free agency yeah i think um
you know each year you go through your
process and and you kind of have to be
you got to evaluate your team first
right and so i think we just were in a
situation where we felt we needed to do
this to to especially to our defense uh
to give us a chance uh uh what we want
to do this fall so um that was really it
um you know we had some ability cap wise
to do it and we thought it was something
that our defense needed i mean preston
smith zadaria smith adrian amos uh you
guys really killed it in free agency i
know it's like quietly killed it yeah
how much conversation do you have you
talked about the defense with mike
pettin as far as the vision of what you
see the defense being yeah i'm sure mike
mike's been there he's you know going
into his second year so obviously going
through last year with him understanding
how uh he wants to play the game with
our team um so obviously having that
kind of uh knowledge moving forward um
uh and obviously our coaches are
involved a little bit with with our free
agency prep but uh now i think it was
something that i think that which is
needed for our football team right now
um we needed to add some some players uh
i was glad that we could add some that
were still you know on the younger side
right best football's ahead of them yeah
um and i thought all these guys would be
good locker room fits as well yeah what
was it about their games that jump
because they're not like superstar names
and you know not household names but me
as a guy who's into x's and o's i mean
preston smith and zadaria smith are
players same with adrian amos right what
was it about them that that made you
guys have pursued them so aggressively
yeah i think we wanted to add some speed
and explosiveness yeah um you know i
think the reliability of those players
as well they've had a nice long you know
career right now they they've played a
lot of football haven't missed much time
right um and again i think the most
important thing for us was just that we
think all three of those guys played
their best football last season and then
their best football should be ahead of
them yeah what would you say to those
brian who
say that with free agency
if you sign guys right out of the gates
you're gonna spend too much
well i think that's correct you know
more than likely that's that's right i
think but it's really not about that for
us i think it's about our football team
and how we're trying to improve our
football team um so you know the top i
think we you know you go through the
process you don't know what
opportunities are to present themselves
but these ones did we thought they could
help us so we pulled the trigger so
you know
there was talks about oh antonio brown
green bay packers le'veon bell
you know were any of those things
discussed uh in the back rooms up in
green bay certainly discussed um don't
know if they were really exactly what we
were trying to do with our football team
those guys are great players um but they
were you know all the options were
discussed when you talk about those
things kind of how it affects your
football team what it can do for you um
and you know obviously with a hard
salary cap you only have so much you can
do um and we we're excited about what we
did yeah we had bill's gm brandon being
with us yesterday and we asked him what
if anything he does to construct his
roster with an eye on the patriots is
there a team that you pay attention to
as you put your players together that
you feel like you need to be more
cognizant of than any others
no i think you i think you look at them
all you look at the trends around the
league and how teams that are successful
the successful teams what they're doing
if they're doing things differently
so we certainly study those things um
but there's not one particular team
obviously i've you know i've worked with
a lot of guys that are that are running
teams right now and i obviously pay a
lot of attention to what they do because
we come from a similar process
background you know um but um
yeah i don't think there's one thing
then you study them all and try to see
what the successful teams are doing and
if you can you know steal anything from
them you obviously will i think a lot of
people a lot of people ask me because
they know i love aaron rodgers but
they're you know why didn't green bay
sign more offensive weapons and you know
my answer to them is well i think that
they're telling you that they're kind of
comfortable with the group they have
some young guys that are kind of coming
up the ranks am i correct with that uh
or please if i'm wrong tell me i'm an
idiot no i i'm excited about some of our
younger players on offense i also think
obviously we're at the beginning stages
of kind of putting this thing together
uh there's still a lot of free agency
left there'll be you know some other
markets obviously the drafts coming up
as well so um you know we're looking at
every avenue to improve our football
team uh you know the beginning of free
agency kind of was defensive heavy uh
that was a little bit by design um but
as we move forward here we'll certainly
uh you know look at the offense as well
right what would you think about the
draft before free agency
i think it's a pretty strong draft this
year no no i mean i'm saying to have the
draft before free agency what would you
think if that would happen um
it's a good question um i'm kind of
i'm kind of for almost uh you know as
soon as the college season's done
getting the medicals done and then
drafting that next week you know wow i
just uh obviously there's a ton of
information uh through this time and pro
days and combines and stuff but uh you
know i've always thought it's what they
do on tape you know that's always been
the most important thing
but uh
um
before free agency i think
i think you'd adjust some things and how
you went about it but um yeah it could
work why do you think then that there's
just the obsession with going from
campus to campus having all these visits
all these workouts is it just we have
the time we have the resources we may as
well use them and yeah and you you think
you could basically do a a good draft
without all of this stuff that we see
from late february to late april yeah
certainly the more information the
better right i mean that it helps you
you know but at the same time i think
that some of us you know um
you know if you do your work in the fall
right maybe you're more prepared you're
ready to go you know um so maybe have a
little bit more advantage i think the
time gives other teams time to catch up
as well so um that's more of a
competitive thing but uh
at the same time i think
that these time is important and if you
have the time you have to do due
diligence with these players to find out
who they are what they're made of how
they're wired um and so that's what
we're doing now
we're seeing kind of a new fad with some
of these guys coming out in the draft
right quinn and williams nick bosa you
know i did my combine i'm going to let
my play speak for itself i'm not going
to do my pro day are you in favor of
that do you think there's more to be
gained by guys of that caliber of doing
something on their pro day yeah i think
if you've if you've done everything at
the combine if you've if you've done all
the testing and you feel good about it
and you're not trying to improve those
times i think that's all you need yeah
you know i think uh obviously there's a
risk involved for these players um
that's the more they do um so for me i
believe if they've done everything at
the comma and they've checked all the
boxes um then they should be good yeah
once the combine's done you just want to
get to know the person right yeah and
just see what they're like football and
everybody looks at it different some
some teams you know really like to get
their hands on them and work them out
and and in a one-on-one type situation
uh and that can be helpful um but uh you
know for us i think once once the
combine's done if you've competed and
you've done everything and you feel good
about it you're not trying to improve
any particular testing then then you
should be good and and you're like in
favor of you know
or i don't know in favor i just like to
hear your thoughts because i know you
know a lot about football like leonard
fournette christian mccaffrey do you do
you downgrade guys like that for not
playing in their bowl game do you look
at them and go oh they gave up on their
team and what's what's the kind of
thoughts that go through your head i
think um the thing when when those
decisions are made um i think we want to
talk to the player and kind of hear it
from them what was their thought process
right you know yeah um at the same time
i think you know
every player situation is different yeah
i think it's important what what their
reasons were behind it right now what do
you think the biggest challenge is going
to be for your new head coach matt
leflore in coming in with a team that
has there's always expectations yeah
franchise quarterback one of the best
ever according to chris and i can't
disagree with that chris says the best
player ever at any position what's the
biggest probably drove that price level
what's the biggest challenge
what's the biggest challenge though from
your perspective and having the new
coach go in and get this get everything
out of this team right away yeah i think
it's probably what's it's what would be
do for every new head coach i mean you
know matt's never been a head coach
before so there's just so many things
pulling at you um i know as a first time
gm you know like the one thing that that
i went through is you tried to protect
your scouting time because that's what
that's what i had done all my life and
all of a sudden people were pulling at
that so i think you know for him i think
it's going to be you know a bit of a big
challenge is just make sure he's
protecting his his football time because
obviously we hired matt because he has
an excellent background and not only
developing quarterbacks but offensive
football and uh and that's that's really
important so um you know
he's going to get pulled in a lot of
different directions even by me
sometimes and he's got to make sure he
protects you know protects that we
didn't get a chance to talk to the
scouting combine we haven't talked to
you since you hired matt lafleur but in
the process of interviewing coaches
talking to coaches what was the moment
where you knew this is my guy
obviously we did a lot of background
work and i'm talking to different people
who had coached with him
worked with him in the past and it was
all really really positive when he get
to sit down one-on-one in an interview
situation and talk about philosophy's
vision for our football team it really
started to come into play his ability to
command our team
i think we were very aligned and kind of
how we wanted to build this thing
and i think just as we went through that
process that interview process you just
you kind of stood out above the rest how
do you project though a guy's ability to
kind of take over a locker room the way
a head coach needs to if he's never been
a head coach and you're basing it on
face-to-face interview what is it you
look for that makes you think this is a
guy who can walk into that locker room
and take charge obviously a lot of it is
the people you talk to have worked with
them for you know years and and some of
the
people and players that he's been
involved with um
but i think also you know like there's a
confidence i think you present yourself
with an interview it's a little small
part of it but it's but it's important
um and i think that uh as we went
through all the checklists i think he
just kind of he kept surfacing as the
guy that looked like the red cadillac
football team all right last one for me
because i know you got more important
things to do maybe not as cool as this
but more important things i mean um are
you ever amazed at the
every four or five weeks the
aaron rodgers leadership thing like you
know just what are the x players whoever
it may be it just always seems to kind
of resurface itself do you get sick of
hearing it i do um i don't i honestly
pay a lot of attention to it but when
you've been around there and for as long
as you know i've been around him and
seen his leadership qualities he just
it's it just doesn't make any sense you
know i don't know if it's you know
people trying to be relevant or what but
it seems like haters like jealous people
a lot of the time i mean everybody leads
in different ways but um obviously i've
been fortunate enough to see
him lead in some tremendous ways and
that's not a concern of mine yeah right
well the season will be here before you
know it's uh note sources say that it
may be the packers and the bears getting
things started week one thursday night
uh 100 season to the nfl 101st season
for the green bay packers i still don't
know how that worked out
you're older than the nfl oh exactly
you're right i didn't even think of that
but it's great seeing you as always
congratulations on your success and all
the best moving forward thanks guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports